all right
i think we can get started eh
so as always welcome everyone if you
have any questions you can ask in the
chat
uh lewis will will be there helping me
so this is the fourth and last chapter
of the course uh
this is a bit different to the previous
three in this one we'll show you a bit
more of how to use the platform
and how to leverage all of the hog in
phase features
so this is the quick agenda for today
first we'll see a bit about the platform
then
we'll show you how to use existing
pre-trained models
then how to push models to the hub both
with the push-to-hop method
and the hook in phase a client
command line interface i then will
talk a bit about model cards and to
close we'll show you like some
bonus content that is not part of the of
the
core of the course
so yeah so the hub and the cognitive
help you've already used it a bit
on the previous chapters it's the
central platform that enables anyone to
discover use and contribute
new state-of-the-art models and datasets
it costs a wide variety of models so it
had
more than ten thousand public available
models we can check
right now how many it has so right now
it has
11 000 publicly available
models for anyone to use
so the hub has support for both models
and datasets
in this chapter we focus completely on
the model side of the hub
so the models in the hub are not limited
to hog and phase transformers
and it's not even limited to natural
language processing
there are modern models from flare and
an alien nlp for
nlp for speech there is asteroid and pi
node
and there is also theme for vision this
is just to name a few
so if you want to see all of the
supported models
in the hub so this is hogginface.com you
can go to
resources and here you can go to model
health doc
and at the left you can look at
libraries and here we have the full list
of supported
libraries and how well supported
they are depending on the different
features
so there is holding phase transformers
but there's also
adapter transformers alien nlp asteroid
esp
net flare by node sentence
transformation
transformers spacey tensorflow tts and
tim
so each of these models is hosted as a
kit repository so if you used github
before this will be very straightforward
to you
ensuring a model on the hub means
opening it up to all the community
it makes the model accessible to anyone
looking to easily use it in turn
it will eliminate their need to turn the
model on their own and it will simplify
sharing and using the model
additionally the hub also has something
called the inference api
so in the moment you upload a model to
the hub
there will be an automatically deployed
hosted inference api
that allows you or anyone else in the
community
to try out the model directly on the
website
so the video will show you a bit more of
this but just so you have an idea of
what i'm talking about
i think we already did a bit of this in
the first chapter
but if you open a repository
here at the right you have a hosted in
friends api
so you can try this query and if you
click compute
this is a field mask
model it will predict
what word should go there so the goal of
life
is life okay so that wasn't great but
you get the idea
and it's not limited to field masks
actually there are like a
a lot of other tasks so
okay i will show you the first video
of this chapter but please feel free to
ask anything in the chat
if you have any questions
in this video we're going to go over the
hogging face model hub navigation
this is the huggingface.co landing page
to access the model hub click on the
models tab in the upper right corner
should be facing this web interface
which can be split into several parts
on the left you'll find categories which
you can use to tailor your model search
the first category is the tasks models
on the hub
may be used for a wide variety of tasks
these include natural language
processing tasks
such as question answering or text
classification but it isn't only limited
to an lp
other tasks from other fields are also
available such as image classification
for computer vision
or automatic speech recognition for
speech
the second category is the libraries
models on the hub usually share one of
three backbones
pie torch tensorflow or jacks however
other backbones such as rust or onyx
also exist
finally this tab can also be used to
specify from which high-level framework
the model comes
this includes transformers but it isn't
limited to it
the model hobby is used to host a lot of
different frameworks models
and we are actively looking to host
other frameworks models
the third category is the datasets tab
selecting a dataset from this tab means
filtering the modules
so that they were trained on that
specific data set
the fourth category is the languages tab
selecting a language from this tab means
filtering the models so that they handle
the language selected
finally the last category allows to
choose the license with which the model
is shared
on the right you'll find the models
available on the model hub
the models are ordered by downloads by
default
when clicking on a model you should be
facing its model card
the model card contains information
about the model its description
intended use limitations and biases
it can also show code snippets on how to
use the model
as well as any relevant information
training procedure data processing
evaluation results or copyrights
this information is crucial for the
model to be used the better crafted a
model card is
the easier it will be for other users to
leverage your model and their
applications
on the right of the model card is the
inference api
this inference api can be used to play
with the model directly
feel free to modify the text and click
on compute to see how would the model
behave to your inputs
at the top of your screen lies the model
tags
these include the model task as well as
any other tag that is relevant to the
categories we have just seen
the files and versions tab displays the
architecture of the repository of that
model
here we can see all the files that
define this model
you'll see all usual features of a get
repository the branches available
the commit history
as well as the commit diff
three different buttons are available at
the top of the model card
the first one shows how to use the
inference api programmatically
the second one shows how to train this
model in sagemaker
and the last one shows how to load that
model within the appropriate library
for bert this is transformers
okay so i think that was quite
straightforward
maybe let me just briefly expand a bit
on
some points so the ui change a bit but
if you click now deploy
accelerated in france you get this code
snippet
so you can make a request in in python
but this is not limited to python this
is like a normal
api call so you can use javascript or
whatever language you use
then here at the right if you click
using transformers you get this cool
snippet that you can use
but as we discussed before this is not
limited to transformers
so if you go to the models
page and at the left you can click here
the plus 19
and here you can see all of the
supported libraries so for example if we
go to sentence transformers
that will filter out all of the sentence
transformers
and here the code snippet will change so
for example here the code snippet
is specifically for this library so that
makes
it very nice like a very nice
integration with other
libraries and if you click here compute
this inference if this
widget is for sentence similarity
so you get a source sentence and then
destinations or
sentences and you will get the distance
between the source sentence
and each of the others so how similar
these are
so uh for this model the closest thing
to that is a happy person is that is a
very happy person
so that makes sense
so there is a question can we use a
keyword based
search to search for models for a
particular task
so if you are interested on a particular
task
you can go to models and you can then
click
text generation for example and then
here you can do like additional search
so for example gpt
you can also have like additional
filters so for library data sets
languages
but we are improving the search
functionality now
so just stay tuned and there will be
like a nicer features
for discoverability of the models
good question though okay
so this was how to use the how to
navigate the hub
let's quickly discuss something that you
will probably be already familiar since
you did this in the first and second
chapters
so let's say that we are interested in a
french based
model that can perform mask filling
so yeah let me remove this so we set
fill mask and you want french
so we can use this one
canvas base normally what you should do
is read the description
and the model card to understand what
this model is about
and what's the purpose and if it has any
biases any limitations
we'll talk a bit more about this in few
minutes
okay so there are like three different
ways of using
the model so the first one is like we
did in the first chapter so we use the
pipeline so this like
this super high level
function so from transformers import
pipeline just specify
what's the task that we are solving
which is field mask
and we specify the name a gun member
base
and as you can see here we get a
prediction
you can also use the specific model
architecture
to load the model this is similar to
what you did in the second chapter
so this is a gaming bird model
it has the cumin bird architecture so
you can import commemorator organizer
and the camembert for masked language
model
and you can do this
a language showed you in one of the
previous sessions
if you go to github transformer source
transformers models
you can see all of the architectures
that are implemented in the transformers
library and as you can see there are
quite a bit so what is normally
suggested is to use the
auto tokenizer and auto model like the
auto classes
because these are architectural agnostic
and then you don't need to worry about
yeah about what's the specific
architecture
so let me just briefly step back to
the pipeline which i think is something
important
is that you need to make sure that the
model you're using the checkpoint you're
using
is for this task so let's say that you
want to use
instead text classification the model
was not trained for this
so of course this will not make any
sense
so it will give you an output but it
will complain
it will say that you probably need to
train the model on a downstream
task as you did in chapter three
and yeah the prediction is pretty much
meaningless
here okay
so this was nothing new but i think that
what will be
more interesting is the next
next section which is how to share
pre-trained
models so these are like the last two
videos of the
first part of the course so the first
one will show you how to manage a repo
and how to upload
files with a command line interface
and the second video will show you how
to use the push to have a
methods so there are like three
different ways of doing things so one is
the web interface
one is using the transformers or calling
phase hub a
command line interface and the third
option is the push to hub api
so let's jump to the video and remember
to ask any questions
in the chat
in this video we're going to understand
how to manage a model repository on the
hogging face model hub
in order to handle a repository you
should first have a hugging face account
aiding to create a new account is
available in the description
once you're logged in you can create a
new repository by clicking on the new
model
option you should be facing a similar
model to the following
in the owner input you can put either
your own namespace
or any of your organization's namespaces
the model name is the model identifier
that will then be used to identify your
model on the chosen namespace
and the final choice is between public
and private
public models are accessible by anyone
this is the recommended free option as
this makes your model easily
accessible and shareable the owners of
your namespace are the only ones who can
update and change your model
a more advanced option is the private
option
in this case only the owners of your
namespace will have visibility over your
model
other users won't know it exists and
will not be able to use it
let's create a dummy model to play with
once your model is created comes the
management of that model
three tabs are available to you you're
facing the first one which is the model
card page
this is the page you used to showcase
your model to the world
we'll see how it can be completed in a
bit
the second one is the files and versions
your model itself is a git repository if
you're unaware of what is a git
repository
you can think of it as a folder
containing files which can be versioned
if you have never used git before we
recommend looking at an introduction
like the one provided in this video's
description
the git repository allows you to see the
changes happening over time in this
folder
hence the term versions we'll see how to
add files and versions in a bit
the final tab is the settings tab which
allow you to manage your model's
visibility and availability
let's first start by adding files to the
repository
files can be added through the web
interface thanks to the add file button
the added files can be of any type
python json text you name it
alongside your adult file and its
content you should name your change or
comment
generally adding files is simpler when
using the command line
we'll showcase how to do this using git
in addition to git we're using git lfs
which stands for git
large file storage in order to manage
large model files
first i make sure that both git and git
lfs are correctly installed on my system
links to install git and git lfs are
provided in the video description
then we can get to work by cloning the
repository locally
we have a repository with a single file
the file that we have just added to the
repository using the web interface
we can edit it to see the contents of
this file and update these
it turns out i have a model handy that
can be used for sentiment analysis
i'll simply copy over the contents to
this folder
this includes the model weights
configuration file and tokenizer
to the repository i can then track these
files with the git add command
then i commit the changes i'm giving
this commit the title of
add model weights and configuration
finally i can push the new commit to the
huggingface.co remote
when going back to the files and
versions tab on the web interface
we can now see the newly added commit
with the updated files
we have seen two ways of adding files to
a repository here
a third way is explored in the video
about the push to hub api
a link to this video is in the
description
unfortunately the front page of our
model is still very empty
let's add a readme markdown file to
complete it a little bit
this readme is known as the model card
and it's arguably as
important as the model and tokenizer
files in a model repository
it is the central definition of the
model ensuring reusability by fellow
community members
and reproducibility of results and
providing a platform on which other
members
may build their own artifacts we'll only
add a title and a small description here
for simplicity's sake
but we encourage you to add information
relevant to how was the model train
its intended uses and limitations as
well as its identified and potential
biases
evaluation results and code samples on
how
should your model be used great for
contributing a model to the model hub
this model can now be used in downstream
libraries simply by specifying your
model identifier
ok feel free to ask any questions in the
chat
item homes you asked so talk can
suddenly come into play
if we are working with organizations
i guess you are referring to the
authentication token
so normally when you log in in your
computer to hog interface
with a cognitive command line interface
every user has a token that is saved
locally
and then in the server when you push
files
the back end make sure that you have
access a
specific file so if you are a member of
an organization and you push
a model or you create a repo or delete a
repo in an organization
you will always need to your token will
will be part of the request but this is
for any request because we need to know
like
which is the user making the request
let me know if that wasn't a very clear
explanation or if you were referring
to another token and not the
authentication token
okay so let me just show you the the
last video and then
we will do some coding if that sounds
good
and in the meantime feel free to ask any
questions in the chat
let's have a look at the push-to-api
just before recording this video
i function the best module onto the glue
mr pc data set
we won't go over the fine tuning code
here because you can find it in any
transformers tutorial or by looking at
the videos linked below
what interests us here is what happens
when the training is finished
and we've got metrics we're happy about
this video requires you
to one sign up for an account under the
acmephase.com website
and two have your authentication token
to that website stored
which can easily be done by typing face
cli login into a terminal
or like this in a collab notebook by
using an exclamation mark
this command won't work if you're using
a regular jupyter notebook
so if you are using that and don't have
access to a terminal
you'll need to copy your access token
from the urgingface.co
website into the training arguments i'll
show you where exactly in a little bit
with that done the push web api will
allow us to upload to the
input server model its configuration and
the associated tokenizer
to use it inside the trainer you have to
make sure
to set push to web equal to inside the
training argument
we can specify a model id for repository
which will default to the name of the
output tier
if we don't say anything we can push to
an organization
as long as we're a member of that
organization and this is where
your organization should be pasted if
you need to
revolve is done we can call
trainer.push2
once the training is finished
in future developments we'll add the
ability to automatically push to the up
at the end of each epoch
or every given number of steps so stay
tuned
the command returns a url for a specific
commit
which we'll be able to inspect if we
copy it in our browser
just before checking that note that if
you are not using the trainer api
you can directly push your model and
your tokenizer to the
by using the push to have method by
passing the commuter role in my browser
i can access my repository
called findtruth.mrpc as expected
and see that several files have been
added a modal card
the configuration of the model the model
weights
the transfer boundaries and all the
files required by the tokenizer
the trainer drafted a model card for us
which contained the final results on the
evaluation set the training upper
parameters
the intermediate training results as
well as the frameworks
i was using if i click edit model guard
to see the raw content
i can see the trainer also generated a
table of metadata that the urging phase
co website
is going to use to properly apply
filters to my model
i can also directly access the transfer
board runs inside the model hub
by clicking training metrics here
now that the model is on the heap we can
use it from anywhere with the from.train
method
we just have to use the identifier from
the hub and we can see that the model
configuration on weights are
automatically downloaded
we can use this model as we would any
transformers model
for instance by loading it in a pipeline
since the mrpc dataset is data set of
pairs of sentences where the task is to
determine if two sentences
are paraphrases of one another or not we
use it on two sentences
separated by sep it's a little bit
disappointing to see that it's
predicting
label 0. that's because i didn't specify
any label when i created the modal
configuration
fixing this is super easy with the
push-to-api
first we can fix the configuration
locally by setting label to id an
id to label with a proper value then
we can push the fixed config to our repo
with the push to a method
once again this returns the url of a
commit which we could inspect and see
the exact diff inside the config
and note that the command is going super
flat because i'm using the same local
folder
as before which on which my repo is
already cloned
once this is done and we create a new
pipeline we can see the new
configuration is automatically
downloaded
thanks to the built-in personaling
system and we get the new label
we can also play with the model directly
on its model card
by passing the text i was using and
clicking compute
i just have to wait a little bit of time
before the model is loaded on the
inference api
and displays the result when the module
is loaded we can double check we get the
same results as before directly on the
widget
try the push to a bpa on your models
today
all right uh yeah going back to the
question from iam holmes about the
authentication token and now that i saw
this example i think that i
understood a bit more where your
question came from
so normally when you do hog interface uh
click login
your authentication token will be stored
in the cache and then you will
you won't need to do it ever again but
for example if you're working in collab
or
yeah i don't know in an environment in
which maybe you don't want to do login
instead you can specify enforce a
specific authentication token
and that's the use case of the auth
token param
okay so let's do some coding
so you will need to do your
configuration in git if you are
yeah your normal git configuration i
already did login before
oh so have a typo here
who i am
sorry it's who am i yeah there we go
so i already did login before starting
this session
so my username is hackardtech
so i showed you a few examples so the
nice thing about the push-to-have
api is that everything including phase
in transformers
has this method so models tokenizers
yeah you name it so if you do this
first three lines it will push
the model file and it will push the
tokenizer file
what is very nice is that if you use the
trainer api
okay now i'm getting an error so let me
just quickly
hmm okay this is new
okay let me try once more
in the meantime let me show you an
example of a repo uploaded with a
trainer
api that if you follow the pytorch
tutorial in chapter
three you are quite familiar so just by
specifying push to hub
you will get a bunch of very nice things
so you will get a
description you will get the loss
accuracy f1 or other metrics
you will get placeholder sections that
you can later on
complete you will get all of the
training hyper parameters
that were used during training you will
get this nice table with the results
during training for every epoch
and you will also get the framework
versions so this is very useful for
reproducibility
on top of this there is this very nice
feature which is hosted
tensorboard in the hub
so if you have tensorboard traces in
your repository
and it's not limited just to hog in
phase transformers like it can be like
any
any tensorboard traces you will get
automatically a
tensorboard deployed for you and here
you will be able to
look at the metrics
okay uh it seems like
i still have problems for some reason
sorry so let me instead just do it
in the terminal this will be easier
[Music]
yeah so let's first
import what we care about
so here we are just initializing a
modern tokenizer
off with as we've done before so nothing
new
okay it may take a bit and then like
this to just
do model dot push to have and then the
name
of the rep so let me just do it
yeah it takes few seconds this command
is uploading
all of the all of the all of the
model for you
i'm actually not sure why i got the
server because i tried it like 10
minutes before
and i was not having this issue
repository not found
[Music]
okay this is taking i think my computer
is
having a hard time with the live stream
at the same time
yeah in the meantime like if you also
want to
specify an organization you can do so
and as we were discussing before you can
also specify
a token if you want
okay so another option is using the
hogging face
yeah i don't know
tokenizer push to help
okay so the repo was created
automatically because it didn't exist
let's see if the files they are still
being uploaded
yeah normally it doesn't take this long
i'm not sure if this is my computer or
if there's any
connection issue right now with hoping
face
[Music]
okay in the meantime while that runs let
me show you like the second approach
which is using the hogging face clay
so if you just hogging basically
repo create dummy 2
it normally creates a record for you
on the hub
yeah so it asks you do you want to
create repo hacker tech
dummy 2 i say yes and it
it gives you both the link to look at it
on the browser and it also tells you how
to clone it
so this similar to what lisand was
making in the first video
here you can do yeah like the normal
things for example you can create a
model card
which is this normal markdown file
so this is a test you can preview it
and you can commit and when you commit
yeah you get here like this is a test
this is what i wrote in the model card
you can look at all of the files
you can look at the history of the
[Music]
repository
yeah and as you can see here i have this
commit
14 seconds ago
in which i did this change so it's like
very nice because if you are used to
github
workflows you can use this to create
branches for example
you can also revert back changes very
easily so it has like very nice
versioning yeah so yeah
okay so going back to the previous one
of the tokenizer
in which i use tokenizer.push2hub if you
go here to files and versions
you can see here that the files were
uploaded now
[Music]
yeah so let me just quickly
check the history
yeah so i think that there was some
connection error and as you can see
actually both the model and the
tokenizer
uh were uploaded so that's good
so what a the whole interface
infrastructure normally does for
transformers it is that it analyzes the
configuration
the configuration specifies a bit like
what's the architecture
uh yeah these kind of things and based
on this
it already tells you like this is a
field mask model it's a camembert model
it's transformers it's using by torch
this is all based on the files and the
config
and you can already use here
the hosted inference api you will need
to wait
especially the first time you need to
wait for the model to load on the back
end
and you can even like if you want to
deploy you can use this in
in the accelerated inference api and
make as many calls you want
uh yeah and play around with the model
and you can
very easily integrate this to your own
products
okay uh yeah so
that was a push to have so okay so we
going back to the command line interface
which was dummy
2 i think no me too maybe
yeah so right now we don't have anything
right we only created a
the model card so let me know
okay let's make computer that is very
slow so what we can do now is
like a normal github
workflow you can do git clone
and then the name of the web so now for
example i already have the wrapper it
just downloaded the readme which is the
only file the git attributes is also
there but it's
a hidden file so you won't see it
unless you specify also like the hidden
files
so as alessandro mentioned in the video
apart from git we also use git lfs
that is git a large file storage this is
super useful for files that are very
large which is very common in machine
learning
so this is for files that are larger
than 10 megabytes
and normally what we do is that you can
specify which extensions
you want to handle with lfs so
yeah all of this
so normally what you need to do is to
do git lfs install just to make sure
it's initialized
and yeah let me show you
a nice example so let's say that we
want to work with a model locally maybe
train it and then
instead of using the push to have we
want to save it locally and then push
so that's what the safe pre-training
method is for
so let me just put the right name which
is to me
too let me now just
copy paste all of these code snippets
so what this is let me just explain line
by line why it runs
is that it will uh the same thing we
load the model we love that organizer
then we save the model in the directory
domito
which is where we clone the repo and we
also save the
tokenizer but as you can see my computer
is having
a hard time with the live stream so it's
a bit slow sorry for that
okay okay
so if you look at now dummy 2
you can already see all of the files so
let's just
enter the repository
and if you do get status it's normal git
you will get like
okay all of these files are to be added
they are not they are not tracked right
now so if you
do get that this will add
all of the files to be tracked
then you can do get status and you will
get a
some things another thing you can do is
get lfs
status this is nice because now you can
see which files
will be used handled with normal git and
which files will be handled by git
large file storage this is just a like
for additional info
it's not something that you need to to
worry too much about
you will need to worry if you have like
a file with a new extension that is very
large
but it's super easy to just add a new
extension so for example you can just
change the the git attributes anyways
let's commit my
first model
super easy and then you just will get
push
this since these are like very large
files normally it takes a bit uh
[Music]
so i'll just keep moving
a bit for now and then shoot
okay so this was pretty much everything
for the sharing pre-trained
models section er let me just quickly
we already saw how to use the web
interface
and this is what we just did which one
is how to upload a file
yeah so as you can see 80 something
megabytes
that's why it's a bit slow even with a
relatively
fast connection okay so the last section
is a bit uh
different it's about how to build a
model card
so we already saw like few model cards
uh
just as a recap the model card is this
file which is
very important it explains the model it
ensures that it's reusable
by the rest of the community and it
provides a platform on which other
members can build their artifacts
so documenting how the training and the
evaluation was done helps
others understand what to expect of a
model
and it will also provide and yes sorry
and providing sufficient information
regarding the data
that was used and the processing and
post processing
that were done ensures that the
limitations biases and context in which
the model is not useful
can be identified and understood so if
you upload a model without anything in
the model card
no one will use it because they won't
know what the model is for
instead if you have like a very nice
model card explaining
what it does how it was trained what's
the purpose what are the limitations
which are the biases
that will be super useful for other
people and additionally as we'll see in
one minute
you can add some special metadata that
will make your model
discoverable by the rest of the
community
so as we saw it's just a rhythmic file
and if you're more interested on this
the model card concept originates from a
research direction from google
the paper is called model cards for
model reporting that's by margaret
mitchell
so there's a lot of very useful
information contained in that paper
so we recommend you to take a look at it
[Music]
there are some sections that we
recommend model description
intended uses and limitations how to use
limitations and bias training data
trading procedure and evaluation results
so these are not a strict we don't force
any
specific sections so the model card
really has a lot of a lot of flexibility
so here there's a paragraph explaining
each of these sections
i think that you can go over it by
yourself but what might be
more useful is to just quickly go
through
quickly go through a very nice model
card
so this is bird-based cased probably
you're already a bit bored of this repo
at the time
we've seen this quite a quite a bit so
it has like few sentences explaining
the model where it was introduced eh
then it has a description of the model
explaining the high level overview of
the model
how it was trained in which objectives
and what was
what is what the model learned so for
example the model learns
an inner representation of the english
language that can then be used to
extract features
useful for downstream tasks so it also
has this intended uses and limitations
section
so yeah it tells you that you can use
this for
mass language modelling or next sentence
prediction
but the intention of this model is to be
a fine tune
on downstream tasks you can also get
here like a
code snippet although now the how to use
section if you're using transformers
you can also just click here using
transformers
and load it from here
uh yeah then it shows you how to do it
in pi torch and tensorflow
a here actually there's a bug here this
is for tensorflow
it should be just paired model and here
it should be df
bird model but anyways
you get the idea then there's a
limitations and bias section which is
very useful
i think it's super important so let's
just read it so
even if the training data used for this
model could be characterized as fairly
neutral
this model can have budget predictions
and this is very similar to what we did
at the end of the first chapter with the
pipelines
so the man worked as a and the
predictions are
lawyer waiter god detective doctor
and as you can see the woman worked as a
nurse
waitress mate so as you can see the
model has some biases
and as it's mentioned here and as we saw
before this bias will also affect
all fine-tuned versions of this model so
it's important that if you pick a model
you need to understand the biases
because very lightly
those biases will probably trans
transfer to your own model as well when
you do
a downstream a sorry when you do fine
tuning
it also explains what's the training
data how the training was done what's
the
pre-processing pre-training a table of
the evaluation results
and finally yeah how to cite it
the model cards are very flexible
just let me quickly show you
the metadata so at the top people can
add a
useful metadata so for example you can
specify what's the language
what's the license what data sets were
used
when training the model you can also add
as many tags as you want so then people
can click here
expert and they will find all of the
models that have this
tag if you would like to learn a bit
more about
the metadata you can go to resources
model hub talk
then you can search here we have a
couple of sections
on metadata but this link in particular
has a an example of the model card and
what's the structure
so which languages you have the license
which tags you want to have so for
example you can use this to specify
a third-party libraries or specific
tasks
data sets metrics and also like a
you can add specific metrics which
can later on be processed by other
pipelines
yeah i think that's pretty much it
feel free to ask any questions
and if not i will show you yeah so this
is the end of the chapter
there are like two very small things i
would like to show you
which are part of the hogging face hub
[Music]
yeah so the first one
let me just go out of this
if you have transformers installed very
likely you already have the hogging face
hub
installed this is a client library that
gives you access to a lot of things so
this is what
allows anyone to push files to to the
hub you can
do a lot of very nice things nice things
and if you
would like to integrate this to your own
code it's very straightforward
apart from having like wrappers to
upload things or download things from
the hub
you also have access to information
information from from the hub so for
example if you would like
to get all of the models
[Music]
that are for a specific library let me
actually
this will return quite a bit so so this
will return information not the actual
models
let's say in film mask i think that that
will be
clever so this will make a call to the
backend
this will return all of the information
on all of the
field mask models
and as you can see there are 1000 va
mask filling models on the hub
so let me just show you the first item
so as you can see the model name is
albert based b1
it gives you all of the tags and it
tells you what what's the task this
model
this repo is for so there was a person
from the community
that was doing the course and they
decided to
actually create a hog and phase data set
of all of the models that are on the hub
so that's quite nice
so if you would like to do model
exploration and more of that
that that's like a fun project that
anyone could already with
this provided so actually you would like
to learn a bit more about
about this the repository is
coginface hot
and this is like the open source place
for everything related to the hub
so you get a client library to download
and publish on the hub
you get the inference api for
third-party libraries
you get the widgets so the widgets are
the things
at the right of the model language the
model card in which you could
try the model directly on the web and
more things so that's very nice
and this is a very recent feature
let me first
a login face click
create dummy three
okay so i'm first creating a wrapper
and i need to specify repo before
properly
i am homes is asking if there is an
option to certify the number of stars
using the hog in face api
yeah maybe wait for next week there will
be some announcements on that so please
stay tuned
as well
yeah so let me test this uh
so right now i created a repo
and let's say this is like context
managers maybe
let's first explain the code
so the hog in face hub has this class
which is repository
which allows you to clone a repository
in a specific directory
so i just did a dummy three
if i'm not wrong and it will clone
yeah from the three and this
is a context manager so you are you've
probably
done similar things with files so you
can do with
repo dot commit my first file
anything that you do now will be
committed to the hub so this is like a
very nice grappler
that will probably make your life easier
just let me quickly check that this will
work
so we import yeah yeah so
this initializes the repository so now
you can do with repo dot commit
so my first file
with open file text
text yeah
okay so this is a
i mean this part right uh sorry with
open file
as far blah blah blah this can be
anything like this this is not limited
to text files you can't do anything that
is creating
so you're probably very familiar with
this the only new thing
is this grappler with repo dot commit my
first file
and now if we go to the hub so let's go
to my
profile yeah here we have
dummy three
and if we go to files we'll see that the
file that i just created
here with this with open file blah blah
blah
is not actually a done for locally it's
done to
commit that to the repository so this is
like a nice way of handling
a file a file
writing on the hub and as you can see
the file is already here
okay so that where those two were like
the two bonus things i wanted to show
you
okay so this is like the last the last
the last chapter
but we will have like some different
activities going on in the next few
weeks
uh we also have in in the forum this
shared your projects section
so at this point you already have all of
the tools to to fine tuning
for example of text classification on a
specific task
so what you can do now is searching for
a an interesting dataset in the hub so
here
in the hub you can go to datasets and
you can search there for interesting
datasets
and you can work on creating a
classification project a
text classification project and it's
quite easy to
it's quite easy to share this and feel
free to comment here
like hey i trained this with what i
learned on the course that would be
awesome
we have one question which is so
advantageous of the repo that commit
context manager
is that we don't need to do a git commit
every time
yeah so this is like a easy programmatic
way
of handling everything with a context
manager it's
mostly like a convenience grouper i hope
that makes sense
all right do we have any other questions
thanks thanks again mark holmes
all right then then thanks a lot for
everyone that was able to join
yeah and see you in the forum